supongamos que tengo una matriz que es
una matriz de gm por n así que tiene m
renglones y n columnas ok entonces
se puede escribir como sigue la puedo
escribir como vamos a escribir los
engranes de a
a 11 que sería el primer renglón primera
columna a 12 primer renglón segunda
columna y así hasta
1 en el primer renglón enésima columna
después tendría un segundo renglón que
sería
a 21 segundo renglón primera columna a
22 renglón segunda columna y de nuevo
podría continuar hasta a2 n bien y si
continuará este proceso continuará esto
hacia abajo
eventualmente llegaría al máximo renglón
y escribiría a m 1 el mismo renglón
primera columna a m2m decimos renglón
segunda columna y finalmente a m n esa
sería la última entrada así que bien ese
es mi matriz a lo que quiero hacer ahora
es definir la transpuesta de la matriz a
la transporta
dispuesta de
y la voy a notar como a con una pequeña
de acá arriba ate ok y que va a ser la
transporta pues la transporta de a va a
ser simplemente el resultado de
intercambiar los en clones y las
columnas de a así que en vez de ser una
matriz m por n va a ser una matriz de n
por m
y veamos quién es
pues el primer renglón de a ahora va a
ser la primera columna de a transpuesta
así que sería a 1-1
a 12 y así hasta
enésima entrada a 1 n noten que lo único
que hice al primer renglón fue
convertirlo en la primera columna de a
transpuesta después la segunda columna
sería el segundo renglón de a así que
sería
a 12 a 22
y así continuaría hasta a2 n y noten
noten que aquí generalmente estos
números hacen referencia a las entradas
de a generalmente cuando escribo a 12
quiere decir el primer renglón en la
segunda columna pero esa es referencia a
la matriz a así que para la matriz a
transpuesta ignoren o traten de recordar
que son de referencia así que lo más
fácil es olvidarse de esto y simplemente
considerar que la entrada a 12
es simplemente esta entrada de acá muy
bien entonces continuando si continuó el
procedimiento eventualmente llegaría al
enésimo renglón que sería la enésima
columna de la trans puesta así que esto
es
m 1
a m2 y así continuaría hasta
m
y eso de aquí esto de aquí es mi
transpuesta noten como por ejemplo esta
entrada es la misma que esta entrada
y esta entrada aquí es la misma que esta
entrada
así que lo único que estoy haciendo es
intercambiando renglones por columnas
esto quizás se vea un poco complicado en
abstracto así que vamos a hacer un
ejemplo vamos a hacer una matriz de dos
por dos
bien pues voy a tratar de usar colores
para que esto se entienda bien así que
voy a usar la matriz be una matriz de 2
x 2 que va a hacer
qué va a ser quién vamos a hacer la
matriz 1 2
es 4 bien entonces quiénes ve
transpuesta
quienes ve transpuesta pues simplemente
tengo que intercambiar renglones y
columnas así que bien el primer renglón
es 12 así que la primera columna debe
transpuesta es 12
el segundo renglón es 34 así que la
segunda columna debe transpuesta es 34 y
también lo podríamos hacer al revés en
realidad podría decir que estoy
intercambiando columnas por renglones y
sería exactamente lo mismo pero bueno
voy a hacer un ejemplo un poco más
complicado para que entendamos bien qué
está pasando
vamos a hacer una matriz nueva vamos a
hacer la matriz c
va a ser una matriz de 4 por 3 vamos a
hacerlo un poco más interesante y quién
va a ser pues la matriz c va a ser la
matriz
va a ser la matriz digamos 101 luego el
segundo renglón va a ser 27 menos 5
el tercer renglón va a ser 4 - 3 2
y finalmente el cuarto renglón va a ser
menos
bien entonces quienes quienes se
transportan pues si tenía una matriz de
cuatro por tres e intercambió renglones
por columnas entonces voy a obtener una
matriz de tres por cuatro
3 x 4
que la tengo que hacer un poco más larga
algo así ok tienes mi primera columna
pues es mi primer renglón de s así que
esta primera columna es 101 simplemente
copiar el primer renglón pero lo puse en
vertical
tienes la segunda columna pues es el
segundo renglón de c así que sería 27
menos 5
qué hay de el tercer renglón perdón la
tercera columna es el tercer renglón que
sería 4 menos 3 2 y finalmente
finalmente la cuarta columna y el cuarto
renglón menos 13
y si se fijan si se fijan realmente no
hice nada demasiado extraordinario
por ejemplo el -5 el -5 está en
segundo renglón
clon
tercera columna tercera columna
y termina aquí
termina acá donde terminó en la segunda
columna
segunda columna tercer renglón
de hacer renglón
notan cómo se intercambiaron en el
segundo renglón tercera columna terminó
en segunda segunda columna tercer
renglón si nos fijamos por ejemplo en
este menos tres
este -3 de ahí estaba en el tercer
renglón
tercer renglón segunda columna segunda
columna
y termina termina aquí
en donde ahora termina en la tercera
columna tercera columna
segundo renglón
muy bien así que esto de calcular las
matrices transpuestas es bastante fácil
bien y antes de despedirme solo quiero
preguntarles qué es o quién es la
transporta de la matriz transpuesta es
decir qué pasa si tomo la transpuesta de
alguna matriz que era la transpuesta de
otra matriz puede saber la matriz
transpuesta intercambiar renglones por
columnas así que la transporta al ha
transpuesto intercambiar columnas por
renglones por ejemplo aquí
intercambiamos el segundo renglón
tercera columna por la segunda columna
tercer renglón y si vuelvo a tomar la
transpuesta intercambiaría esto por el
segundo renglón y la tercera columna así
que regresaría a mi posición original
por lo tanto la transpuesta de la trans
puesta es simplemente mi matriz original
y bueno espero que esto les haya
resultado interesante